the alleged gunman in El Paso Texas
posted his anti-immigrant manifesto to
the online message board 8chan minutes
before the shooting CloudFlare the
network provider for hn has since
announced it is dropping the site but
the el paso suspect was not the first to
use hn other mass shooting suspects have
done the same Jeff the gaze is here Jeff
what's being done to prevent shootings
like this well good morning just a few
months ago the FBI created and enhanced
a special task force to study active
shooter incidents their goal has been to
find ways to prevent them by looking for
similarities in links according to
current and former law enforcement
officials many attackers are inspired
online and message boards and social
media are giving attackers the platform
they seek many recent shootings share a
troubling connection the accused killers
have left a blueprint for their alleged
actions on social media like the attack
in a Pittsburgh synagogue last year in
which 11 people were killed and the
massacre in Christchurch New Zealand in
which 51 were killed Nate Snyder is a
former counterterrorism official in the
Department of Homeland Security do you
have would-be recruiters and provokers
who are using these platforms to get to
people on a personal level the post are
out in the open but difficult for law
enforcement to spot unless they get a
tip before an attack happens inside this
conference room in an unmarked building
the FBI has been working to prevent
future attacks
analysts combed through dozens of recent
active shooting cases agent Andre
Simmons says they have been looking for
patterns it's not really accurate to say
that someone just snapped not at all in
fact what we found is that all of the
shooters in our study certainly planned
and prepared many shooters spent almost
two years two years planning their
attack FBI studies have found that only
25% of active shooters had ever been
diagnosed with mental illness and that
shooters aren't typically loners 27% had
significant online interaction yeah
a heightened interest in weapons and
explosives the FBI tells us they receive
three to four referrals a week of people
who've landed on law enforcement's radar
but in the majority of cases people who
see the signs of trouble before mass
shootings often don't call police and
the motivating factors are they the same
or different they vary usually it's a
desire for some omnipotent control even
if it's just momentary there's also a
degree of a desire for infamy and
notoriety in a rare statement from the
FBI the bureau said the attack in El
Paso quote underscores the continued
threat posed by domestic violent
extremists and perpetrators of hate
crimes alright Jeff and so much
information that investigators have but
yet they stopped a lot of things that we
don't hear about this but you can't
necessarily prevent some of these things
that we continue to report on oh that's
right I mean it's a tough task they're
trying with that unit there to boil down
some of the symptoms if you will of an
impending attack so that they can reach
out to the public and say hey here's
what you can look for but it's hard
getting those one or two things to look
for to make it easy for people to spot
yeah and getting somebody say something
as you said in your report it's the idea
of if you see something say something we
did we started with that and that I
think is what's so troubling is that you
have people who see the signs people
going and buying weapons or things like
that but yet they don't report right
exactly thank you Jeff